[Music]
okay
m summa 14 let's go now f3
is um okay so he this is one of those
people who does something crazy and
hopes to intimidate you
from yesterday we know what we do if
people do this what do we do in such a
position
how do we actually play in such a
position when our opponent tries to
intimidate us with
crappy moves we play normally we occupy
the center with pawns
and then we support that center with
pieces okay there's no
other way to do it now he goes knight f6
now remember why you never play f3 one
of the reasons that you never play f3
okay let's play knight f6 to support the
pawn of the knight how do we actually
how do we actually try to
how do we actually try to exploit the
fact that he's played f3
how do we try to explain how do we
prevent it from castling in the long
term
where are we going to put them okay
first of all i go to c4 so he continues
to push pawns
and weaken his squares we just drop the
knight back
he's doing nothing but weakening his
position
exactly bishop c5 to stop him from
castling the long term
okay so okay h4 again this guy is doing
all sorts of random crap and we do not
need to do
anything to actually meet that okay we
can just play normally let's just
develop our pieces
um let's just develop our pieces
and uh i guarantee you guys that this is
going to work a lot better than anything
crazy
i don't like this pin okay i don't like
this pin can we do something about this
pen
what can we do about this pin
yeah h6 just chase the bishop now if he
takes and plays knight e4 we'll deal
with that when he does it i've seen that
okay he continues to play terribly i
mean look at okay knight defender this
is where a lot of people be like oh no
you know he's put a knight on a good
square he has
one piece on a good square big deal we
just dropped the queen back we don't
want to give c7 up and then we're going
to get this knight out of d5
and he's going to be left with nothing
but weaknesses okay
so let's see what he does i mean this
guy is really not playing very well
so really the only thing to remember
here is to continue developing naturally
and not get intimidated by crap okay so
he wants to play b4
and chase our bishop away can we just
piss him off by stopping b4
can we be prophylactic here even though
that's completely unnecessary
but i want to show you guys how
frustrating it is for people to have to
deal with
you constantly stonewalling their ideas
he reinforces the threat of b4 how do we
stop before again
how do we stop before again
yeah we go a4 you go we go a4
because we want to meet bb4 with the on
poisson this is a very typical technique
that's used in a lot of different lines
and obviously he still has gone before
but it's not the same
now how do we chase the knight away from
d5
while also improving the positions of
our pieces
there is a great way of doing that while
also improving the positions of our
pieces
simple simpson amazing we could go
bishop e6 but perhaps we dropped this
pawn
so what i'm gonna do is go knight to d4
bishop e6 would also be good
and then we're going to play c6 and
chase the knight out of d5
if you think about it the best way of
chasing a piece out of a square squares
with a pawn
if we chase a piece out of a square with
a pawn we virtually guarantee
that that piece is not going to ever
again move back onto that square
and he's in huge trouble now we get to
the actual process of winning
he's got 93. now what can we do in this
position we can continue developing with
castles but
there's also free stuff that we can take
there's also free stuff that we can take
and we can start taking that free stuff
okay but would we play rook takes a3 and
how should we help him trade some pieces
would we play rook takes a3 and help him
trade pieces
no he will play bishop takes it here
because no we are threatening to return
to b4
and pin his rook to his king rook takes
a3 would be fine as well
so in addition to everything else we are
just going to win all of his pieces here
he basically has to move his king out
which is just a disaster i mean this is
this is a hot mess yeah but should be
four
this is over this is completely game
over and uh
he's got very few chances to survive i
think he continues to push response
he's doing his best okay a lot of people
here would automatically grab the rook
we don't do that we spot for a second
the flaw of this move which is that it
blunders the queen not only that
he can't even take the knight back he's
dropping everything here
he's dropping everything here
okay so we didn't do anything in this
game all we did was develop our pieces
and um let me be very very clear
i am not trying to laugh at my opponent
here these guys are doing everything
they can
they don't know that they're playing me
i'm sympathetic to that
so i'm not trying to make fun of anybody
here
in fact the reason i'm doing the
speedrun is to help players like msume14
and i hope he's watching the stream
but if you are a player who likes
offbeat openings
i would highly advise against stuff like
this
unless unless um you have fully mastered
an opening and when you're 16 1700 and
you want to play some offbeat stuff okay
that's a different story but this kind
of stuff
it might intimidate players in your
rating range but you're not building
sound fundamentals i talked about this
yesterday
you aren't building sound fundamentals
that you can build off of later and
you'll get stuck at a certain level
okay so first we control the center
take now how could we ensure that we
control the center with pawns
could we ensure that we control the
center with pawns instead of going
knight of six and recapturing the knight
and i like this move that you guys are
about to find
okay so the move d4 i want to talk a
little bit about the move d4 this is a
big mistake
this is a big big positional mistake why
and a lot of people make this mistake so
listen up the correct move
hori plation is to play c6 that is
correct
that's okay that's why i'm here i'm here
to help you understand why this is a
mistake morrigan i love that you
suggested this
um and i want people to keep doing that
okay we learn by making mistake
mistakes the reason a move like d4 is a
mistake is because it closes the center
now you might be like how does it close
the center well it literally creates a
little bit of a wedge
that makes the center more close and
more specifically if you go bishop c5
the bishop is just going to now stare at
the pawn
so you give him an easier time to castle
remember
when we keep the pawn on z5 we're able
to put the bishop on c5
and basically prevent him from castling
okay so
by playing d4 you might argue but wait a
second daniel don't you cramp
white's position right don't you get
more space you do
but space isn't everything in such a
position
he can work around the pawn and get his
pieces developed and yes he's going to
be slightly worse he's going to be
cramped
but he would much rather be cramped and
developed than not cramped and getting
checkmated
so a closed center is not bad in general
but here's what i would say
closed center positions are hard to play
if you're a beginner because they
involve a lot of maneuvering slow play
but there's a lot of openings that are
completely good openings
which involve a closed center one
example is the advanced french which is
good for both sides
the advanced french is an opening in
which white closes the center
voluntarily it's one of the best weapons
against the french
but it's a very hard opening to play for
a beginner because it involves knowledge
of a lot of deep positional themes
another opening which i play which
involves a close center is the king's
indian main line
in the king's indian main line which i'm
just going to very
quickly show you guys white very often
plays d5
closing the center and what happens when
you have a closed center is
oftentimes the situation which is called
attacks on opposite sides
when you have a closed center you
basically shake hands with your opponent
and say okay
we're not doing anything on this little
sliver of the board
so i'm going to take this side of the
board
that i'm going to delineate and i'm
going to delineate with arrows that are
not orange
in order to not confuse the people and
for some reason i'm not able to draw
other errors
whoa sorry sorry sorry sorry guys you
got the point
white was attacking on the um black was
attacking on the king's side white was
attacking on the queen side my apologies
for this
um okay so whatever
um black is attacking here
white is attacking on the queen side and
the question then becomes whose attack
outweighs the other for some reason it's
not letting me draw any other arrows i
don't know why but
it is what it is you guys get the point
um
one moment please okay
so that's what happens when a sensor is
closed and obviously as you guys can
understand it's very difficult
to manage attacking on one side and
defending on the other so that's the
reason why
oftentimes i recommend openings where
the sensor is kept
open so that you get more possibilities
for tactics
i hope that makes sense i'm explaining
this in a very general level there's a
lot more specific stuff to to
go into there and i will now hear my
opponent instead of
trying to develop his pieces as best he
can continues to push his funds
and create very big weaknesses in the
center and of course we play bishop zepa
where should white have put the bishop
here and this probably is white's last
chance to get a
halfway reasonable position of course
he's much worse
where should wider put the bishop
and why if you guys have been morrigan
that's freaking right you get him girl
bishop b3 is correct to stop bishop c5
okay you want to develop in order to
stop your opponent from developing his
pieces on good squares
that is a very high level way of
developing when you're developing your
pieces you not only want to think about
the most active squares for your pieces
bishop g5 technically
is the most active square for white's
bishop but there is a greater priority
here which is to stop black's bishop
from coming out onto c5 and controlling
this diagonal
and after this he goes h4 he exacerbates
the situation
we get rid of the pin okay had he gone
94
if we wanted to preserve the bishop what
would we have done we can go queen e7
and this is fine but if we wanted to
preserve the bishop
what would have also been possible here
yes bishop before check is good um
and and then we can move the queen and
and then we can slide the bishop back to
c5
later on after we get rid of the knight
okay
um so so here rook b1a5 is a
prophylactic move to stop b4
we didn't need to do this we could have
just developed we could have gone bishop
e6
and b4 is not scary but i wanted to show
the principle of prophylaxis i wanted to
show how effective it is
in certain positions to prevent your
opponent from doing what he wants to do
on poissons
obviously this doesn't get the same
effect in fact it just weakens his pawn
and gets things worse
we get rid of the knight we take the
pawn we pin the rook
we take the queen we win the game so in
fact
really the trouble started when we
stopped him from playing b4
people are very stubborn about their
ideas so when you actually take the time
to prevent people from doing what they
want to do
and this hap this is true all the way up
to the grandmaster level
it's very very disconcerting that's why
players such as tigran petrossian and
anatoly karpov
were so good at chess because not only
were they good in all areas but they
also
went out of their way to prevent the
opponent from
making things happen it is a medical
term that's where it comes from
um amrad summer says why not b6 instead
of a4
uh well b6 doesn't actually stop before
maybe it it defines it a little bit but
it doesn't actually stop white from
playing b4
i struggle with moves like a4 i just
never know what to play well i mean
you play it now here's the thing i want
to make very clear before we move on to
the next game
yeah nimisevich was basically the father
of prophylactic thinking and he lives in
the
first half of the 20th century you you
don't want to stop
every single threat right for example
in a position like this i would not say
oh white wants to push his pawn to h5
and i'm going to go h5
you can take prophylactic thinking way
too far and a lot of beginners actually
do that they're afraid of ghost threats
they're afraid of things happening that
aren't actually going to happen or
even if they are or not dangerous that's
one of the hard things about
prophylactic thinking is you don't know
when is a threat significant enough that
you need to stop it
and i can't give you guys a one sentence
method to determine that that comes with
experience
and it comes with getting better at
evaluating danger which is something
that we're going to talk about
progressively as we get onto a higher
level
okay but hopefully this game is a
worthwhile introduction to prophylactic
thinking when it actually works
um so i'm going to write this down
queen d4 he could have stopped the
matrix okay we're playing at 800. that's
actually the first time we are playing
in 800 so let's uh
focus and hopefully this game is going
to go well he goes e3
again one of those moves where we just
respond by occupying the center this is
kind of a reverse french i think it's
called van
i'll take questions after this game
okay knight c3 so again he does random
stuff
and we're just going to occupy the
center the queen is defending the pawn
it's okay it's my pleasure to do this
but i always appreciate support
subs everything is always appreciated
never expected please don't feel guilty
for just being a helpful viewer that is
also very much appreciated but i do
obviously um
greatly i'm very very grateful for all
of the support as well okay so he goes
d4
now charm i think for the prime now this
is a good example of
playing with a close center i am going
to close the center
and i'm going to show you guys how to
play with a closed center i'm going to
give you guys an introduction
to playing with a closed center now he
gives us a check which is actually a
completely empty check
which allows us to actually support our
center how can we block this check
how can we block this check and
simultaneously
give some support to the center yeah c6
and we're getting
get out of there get out of there and we
get a nice little pawn chain that's
basically
giving us a small advantage now let's
continue developing
let's first develop this bishop where do
you guys think we should put this bishop
thank you kimble
s and bits where should we put this
bishop
um d6 is right so a lot of people want
to put it on b4
um and i will explain after the game
why bishop b4 is bad or it's not bad but
it's not great he goes bishop g4
and what he wants is that if we take the
bishop he gets his queen out
and that queen is going to attack g7 do
we need to take his bishop
a lot of people suggesting f5 which
sends the bishop back that is a
fantastic move get out of g4 we could
have also
simply developed our knight to f6 and
made him take our bishop he's giving us
a check it's not doing anything other
than
helping us develop a very nice pawn
chain
now let's continue developing how do we
continue developing
nothing no rocket science here we just
continue developing
we've got a nice pawn pyramid let's
continue developing with knight f6
knight h3 we're going to castle okay
nothing no rocket cycle knight g5 again
he's making moves that aim to intimidate
us but they actually do
absolutely nothing how do we get this
knight out of here let's go h6 and get
that knight oh my god okay so he
blunders his knight
he's his mistake is that he's not
actually developing he's just moving the
same piece over and over again
that's not okay now he offers us to open
the center
should we open the center yes or no
are we ready to open up the center now
that we are up a piece
we absolutely are ladies and gentlemen
we absolutely are
because we have not only an extra piece
and as you guys know one of the
fundamental principles of
operating with extra material is that
you want the centers to be open for that
material to show itself
the second thing is that we have most of
our pieces developed
and his pieces are super passive he
takes with a bishop
by taking with the bishop he leaves the
e4 square extremely weak
so let's put a knight there what other
move do we prepare by playing knight e4
and what pawn do we take with
what pawn do we actually take with
and this is very important guys we take
with the f pawn to stop him from
castling yes beautiful
we take with the f1 to stop him from
guessing now the king only one is gonna
hunt it down
let's go after him how what does that
mean how do we go after him
how do we go after him um
we we can trade the rooks that would be
fine but there is a far better
and far more effective which is
screenage
spread out very good check
if he goes g3 to cover the check we are
just gonna take that pawn on h2
but we're gonna do that only after a
preliminary move
we're gonna see let's see what he does
he should actually move his king out
and try to escape he's completely lost
here and after king d2 i'm gonna make a
very instructive move
okay so what move should we play before
taking the pawn in order to draw his
king
closer to the center of action let us
first take the rook we're not doing that
to trade
we're doing that to get us king a little
bit closer
to the king side and now we're going to
take the pawn on h2
what is our next move going to be how
are we going to actually deliver the
checkmate
nerd nation is suggesting a beautiful
idea we know according to one of our key
principles
that in situations when we're close to
checkmating our opponent one thing that
people often forget
is to involve all of the pieces in this
case
look at this rook on a where does that
rook belong
okay we don't actually need the rook
here we have enough pieces to finish
them off where is the mate i want people
to find the mating sequence it's made of
two
and in fact there's many ways the rook
is sad because it doesn't participate
but we don't need it to participate we
take
it's not mate he goes king f1 where is
the mate i want people to give me two
possibilities for checkmate
what are two checkmating moves queen f2
is one and what's the other
i'm going to make the other move because
it's very elegant come on guys what's
the other one bishop h3 is beautiful
mate game over okay so let's
deconstruct what happened in this game
this is our introduction to playing with
the close
center the center didn't say close for
long now the funny thing is
it would actually have been hard to keep
the center open
because had we played knight c6 in order
to defend the pawn
what would be the problem with the move
knight c6 what would be the problem with
this move
what would be the problem with this one
this is kind of like a reversed french
with an extra tempo for y yeah d takes c
and if we take there are more attackers
on d5 than there are defenders
and so knight takes d5 drops the central
pawn there's no need for for us to allow
this
and uh and so for that reason um and so
for that reason
we have to decide what to do we can take
on e4 but we decided to go e4
okay so for the high rateds among you
and i know you guys are very patiently
watching and i know not everything
is interesting a relatively high level
piece of advice one of the key
concepts when you have a closed center
is to attack essentially the base of the
pawn chain aaron nimsovich that guy i
mentioned
remember that name aaron nemesevich
because i'm gonna be mentioning that
name pretty often he's a pretty
important character
he was also an [ __ ] in real life but
the guy really developed a lot of chess
theory and knowledge
keep that name in mind aaron namsovich
aaron nimzovich in addition to
advocating for prophylaxis
talked about the concept of attacking
the base of the punching what does the
base of the pawn chain mean well if you
have a pawn chain
is the base e4 or is the base d5
he does die on the end but before he
dies he develops a lot of chest thinking
the base is obviously d5 e4 is called
the tip
by attacking the base of the pawn chain
it's like removing it's the same
philosophy as removing
the jenga block at the bottom of the
structure before the whole thing topples
right
we don't remove the top of the block if
we want it to topple we remove the
bottom
okay so it's the same thing the tip will
collapse if the base is attacked
so what in white's position from that
perspective
has been a mistake what move should he
not have made and why shouldn't he have
made it
what move would he like to take back
bingo
white wants a damn pawn on c4 and so a
move like knight b1 would actually be
possible now let's go back to the french
which i mentioned
in the french advance and i claim that
you guys can now find black's best move
without knowing anything about the
theory of this opening
what is black's best move in this
position c5 is correct beautiful
and after c3 white defends sometimes
black actually tries to go b5 b4
okay literally attacking the base of the
pawn chain
i know that b2 is the base but this is a
little bit too slow
so the further down the pawn chain you
go the more pawns are liable to collapse
this is called undermining
this technique is called undermining and
in the french what
what black tries to do often times is to
attack
the pawn on d4 that's why we do knight
c6 and queen b6
and caracon is very similar i can show
you plenty of games that have been won
by attacking the base of the pawn chain
i can show you some of my own games
okay so that's a very important
positional concept it sounds very
complicated
but i think you guys should all
understand the philosophy
behind it so that is why closing the
center is favorable for us in this case
because our pawn chain is very nicely
protected
in fact by playing bishop b5 he actually
helps us build an even stronger pawn
chain
so he's helping us do our bidding you
can also attack the tip of the pawn
chain that's a
that's a legitimate strategy you can do
this as well to try to get some air
space for the bishop
okay so continuing he's just shuffling
his bishop around
and look at the spawn on e4 it's making
it very difficult for the night to come
out
it's also making it very difficult for
the knight to come out here because
we're just going to take the knight and
ruin the structure
somebody is asking when he played bishop
what about bishop dc the problem with
bishop d7
would be that after bishop takes d7 we
would have to take with a queen to keep
the spawn protected
so bishop d7 isn't so much bad as
c6 is good and i want you guys to
understand that there are certain
positions where
a lot of moves are fine but one of the
moves is more conducive to the general
goals in your position
so after bishop's do bishop d6 he's just
shuffling his bishop around
we're sending that bishop away we could
have also played knight f6
and uh by we're basically what my friend
dana mckenzie calls moving our
opponent's pieces
white has just moved his bishop 15 times
and done absolutely
nothing we have already developed a
bunch of our pieces
so what should whites blacks why should
white's plan be here he shouldn't trade
the light squared bishops
he should actually try to trade the dark
squared bishops and for the higher rated
guys among you
what is a plan to try to to try to
exchange the dark square bishops what
can white try to do
and believe it or not this is a very
typical plan in the french
this is a very typical plan in the
french with colors reversed
how does white try to get rid of this
terrible french bishop
bingo b3 a4 bishop a3
if you guys look at french games you
actually often times see
precisely this plan being applied with
caller's reverse
it's not rocket science you're trying to
get rid of your worst piece and you're
developing a plan
to try to get rid of that piece in fact
let me show you guys an example of that
just
just to show you guys that i'm not lying
all of this can be observed
in the french which is the closest
opening to this pawn structure
here we go here's an example of how when
i did this here is an example of when i
did
exactly this thing 10 bucks from lapin
dorito thank you so much
of course i appreciate it very sweet
would not be possible without your guys
support here you go
literally word of her word here we go
my game against jean-marc de grave i did
play the french
a couple of times in my chess career
this game is from 2016 i'm playing a
french grandmaster
it is black to move i want everybody in
the chat to tell me the next three moves
that i played with black
because they are identical to what we
just talked about just with colors
reversed what are the next three moves i
play
b6 okay i want at least several people
because it is lit morgan you are amazing
everybody is amazing
b6 queenie two to stop bishop a6
a5 bishop basics okay and so
i traded the bishops and that was good
for me and i got a nice position
in the end the game ended in a draw
because it was very complicated but i
managed to trade off the lights for
bishops
so again we continue to see that at the
grand master level a lot of these plans
are actually completely understandable
but if you were to look at these moves
without this
entire introduction you might think oh
grand master pawn move so mysterious
in reality it's not mysterious at all
i'm just trying to trade off my worst
place piece which is a very typical idea
in the french
okay um so sorry for the detour just
wanted to show this to you guys so you
know
what what is behind this idea
um and here he should have considered
doing the similar thing now
we just developed he should have castled
here and kept developing in his own
right and then one of our plans here
would have been to attack on the king's
side how do we attack on the king's side
well one good way to attack with a
center being closed is a pawn storm
how do we orchestrate a pawn storm we
want to play g5 and f4 but we cannot
play g5
because the knight is guarding that
square how do we prepare g5 thank you
heard that with a twitch prime
how do we prepare g5 and just give me a
second guys i need to send a message
in the meantime keep thinking
okay h6 is correct h65 and f4 now h6
let's make some empty moves right you
cannot play f4 but maybe you could you
actually can play a four you can
consider it because after e takes f4
and i will introduce now the concept of
an intermediate move or
as they say in italian intermezzo or in
german exhibitions
an intermediate move is a move that is
made before another move
to prepare that other move so what can
you do now what can you do now
bishop takes h3 now white has f takes g5
which is why this gets complicated but
let's
simplify this by saying white takes
morrigan
asks a an amazing question and as this
nighthawk
at our level are you concerned that we
push the pawns in front of our castle
king fantastic question
bear with me for a second here guys
obviously as i have said before you guys
know the principle do not push pawns in
front of your castle king
and that is most of the time true but
this is where i start to talk about
violating strategically violating
principles which you need to learn how
to do in order to get better
why is it actually justified here well
the reason
there's two reasons there's a push and a
pull effect
first of all look at the king side does
white have any pieces
on the king's side other than his king
no he doesn't right he doesn't
and it's very hard for him to get his
queen somewhere to g4 h4 because his
bishop
is blocking the queen so that's number
one number two
even if white tries to get pieces onto
the king's side it will be way too slow
because what black is already
threatening f3 where is this bishop
going
where is this bishop going nowhere it's
trapped
so black is so fast here that
white's king weakness is a lot more
significant than black's king's weakness
black has more possibilities on the king
side okay
i'm trying to find an analogy here okay
queen d7 and queen takes h3
all right it's like a lottery ticket
drops from the sky and you know
that you're gonna win the lottery
whoever it's like a hunger games
scenario
right outside of my window on the road i
see a lottery ticket
and um i'm here
and usain bolt is equidistant from that
lottery ticket
so we're racing who's going to win who's
saying bolts are me obviously usain bolt
right we're usain bolts
and white is like me and we're thinking
and the lottery ticket is the king side
attack
black is obviously so much faster here
so that's the judgment call that you
have to make
but daniel how do i learn how to make
that judgment call well you just saw the
logic and it's difficult
i want to be clear that these judgment
calls are precisely
what define chess mastery it's difficult
to make them
you can make misjudgments i can show you
plenty of games where i opened up the
king side mistakenly
thinking that my opponent had no attack
and it turned out that i was wrong
that's just chess okay so that's how to
think about it
not to be too long-winded here but
instead he just
i mean had he gone back to h3 he would
have actually helped us start attacking
and instead he blunders the knight and
here we open up the center
another complicated thing about the
center being closed
is that you always have to think about
who benefits in the case of the center
getting opened
here we are up a piece and we have much
better development
so we are the ones who benefit uh
because obviously
center getting opened helps us attack
faster
okay any questions about this game
before we get to the next one
any questions about this game before we
get on to the next one
exo521 asks why trade dark and not light
squared bishops well
look at this light squared bishop look
at it it's terrible it's staring at the
pawn it's not doing anything and it has
no prospects
it can just go to the miserable d2
square now the light squared bishop at
least it's controlling some squares
at least it's controlling some squares
it's not great but it's doing something
the bishop is just permanently consigned
to the dungeon thank you dr lambo for
the twitch prime
how do you deal with lots of pawn moves
in the opening well as i explained
one of the crucial things is to adhere
to basic opening principles you want to
keep developing even if your opponent is
just moving pawns around
okay um that's basically
the fundamental thing you want to abide
by but you also want to look for tactics
so you don't just want to close your
eyes and develop
you also want to see if your opponent
isn't blundering anything
okay um i i feel that i understand that
morgan is taking but but yeah that's
that's actually a classic thing and i
feel the same way when i watch
carlson explain his move oh i can play
like magnus but then i play and i feel
dumb um how do you know which bishop is
better well
again guys i'm not using anything that
you guys aren't
seeing i'm literally looking at how many
squares a piece is controlling and
whether it has the possibility
of eventually developing to a good
square
um now it is also important to realize
and i'm going to make a small detour
before the next game
that there are cases when you have a
piece which looks terrible
and that piece looks so bad you're like
man that piece is never going to be good
again
but you want to always entertain the
possibility that a piece will one day
far in the future in 2025 open up and
sometimes you have a piece that is
currently terrible
but if it opens up will be the ultimate
beast and will win you the game
okay and sometimes this is one of the
beautiful things about chess
you want to think in the long run and
you actually want to keep a piece on a
square where it looks really bad
with the knowledge that one day that
piece is going to get opened up
and it's going to decide the game in
your favor that's also a difficult
judgment to make
daniel do you have a game to show me
what the hell you mean i do
here is one of my games from 2008 to
show you guys what i mean by that
okay so let me fast forward to the
critical moments
of this game
okay so this is a game sorry this was
not san francisco this was actually reno
i don't know why it's a san francisco
um
reno okay so this was in re oh sorry
this was yeah this was in reno
um and take a look at my position
i have what is my worst place piece
what is my worst place piece what piece
looks awful
what piece looks awful
yeah look at this look at this piece of
crap look at this piece of crap
okay now but let's take a look at a
scenario
let's imagine imagine for a moment
imagine for a moment that the pawn was
gone from e4 imagine that it could
magically make the pawn disappear for so
for example let's say plus f5 which is
terrible and i play
do you guys see how amazing this bishop
is it just it
x-rays it skewers black's entire
position this becomes the ultimate beast
i am white guys the
the player listed first is white okay
and we're all we're going to be facing
the side that i'm showing the
instructive
elements for it's not always going to be
me sometimes it's going to be my
opponent
so i judged in this moment that i should
probably keep the bishop on g2 and not
try to improve it and put it on h3 for
example because i thought that maybe one
day
this bishop gets opened up and that it's
gonna be the beast but look at what
happens
we play we play here i found a really
nice tactic rook takes f7
he cannot take the rook i'm not gonna
delve too deeply into this because
that's not the point
but basically he has to give his queen
up for two rooks queen g5
queen takes c5 queen takes d4 and guess
what move i play now
guess what move i played now and i know
i'm going fast i'm just trying to
illustrate the ultimate concept
sorry and look at this look at this
monster look at this monster
compare this position to this position
huh
now it's the beast that wins the game
and it delivers the penultimate check
it is the piece that powers white's
mating attack
he cannot take back onto b7 because
guess what peace supports the queen
on mary and i thank you annika for
gifting to morrigan it is
the bishop so sometimes there are
exceptions to the rule sometimes you
want to keep a piece on a particular
square
um where it one day is going to be very
good but i can also show you the flip
side of this
sometimes a piece is just miserable and
sad for the rest of the game and you can
even give up material
to make a piece like this happen one of
the saddest games in my ex
in my life was my game against alexander
ownership from the 2015 us championship
where i had a bishop on aaa look at my
bishop on eight i'm playing black
this was this actually was famous anish
geary
after this game tweeted i wish i
something like i wish i was in
naredinski today
um that's what he said because of my
bishop on eight this bishop is never
gonna get out it's actually a hilarious
situation they could jam jam five gifts
itself there we go
it's a hilarious bishop on a8 which is
never going to get out and even though i
am up a pawn
black is completely lost because i am
basically down a piece i resigned the
game
up upon because he just gets in with his
king and he takes all of my pawns
okay because my bishop is never gonna
get out so that also happens there's two
sides of the coin
okay that is actually a very sad
situation so i'm actually not going to
concentrate on it any further
let's go back to the speedrun and let us
begin the next game
[Music]
you